[Music]
the only song that today is very well known
Hello hello
very nice
very nice because they
feel already big
Look why
sometimes they are all wet they go to the
beach and today put on your shoes it can
break your feet don't tell me I'm yagana
[Music] they
believe it Hello I think that we, the
generation of us, are a bit
more shy than we were ashamed to
say that we are legal
[Music]
I have a great  connection
but that connection has been
increasing in the search because
we have a memory that is
lost somewhere and that we have been
finding little by little and we are
looking for it and we are also finding it and
that memory is precisely in the
territory
[Music]
[Music] [
Music]
we are
[Music]
setting sail from the port of Punta Arenas
here in the Strait of Magellan and
for the next three weeks
we will be exploring places in the
fjords of Chilean Patagonia
is a program of National  Geographic
that is dedicated to exploring AND trying to
protect the last wild places in
the world's oceans
[Music]
we work with governments,
local communities, scientists, NGOs to
all study these places and try to
protect them from threats such as fishing and
also pollution,
it is very  It is important to work with
native peoples and
local communities because they have been the true
custodians of the seas in the
most fragile places on the planet
[Music]
It has been a long time since I considered myself
Chilean,
if I could change it in my
identification record, I would
too  It would be an advance towards a
plurinational state that really values
indigenous peoples, not only in the
verb. I
hope we can find the formula
to protect the territory. That is
what I hope from this trip.
The support of science is important
because there are very few organizations
that come and talk with the indigenous people,
so for us that is a
super important step. I
have been on many
National Geographic expeditions but this one is very
special. We have invited representatives
of the Cahuáscar people and the  sore people
who are going to contribute with their wisdom and
ancestral knowledge to be able to
understand the value of these waters,
not only biologically but also
in those cultures
[Music]
Juan is a fisherman and has told us his
stories when he navigated through
very difficult places nearby  From Cabo de Bonos,
for example,
and Leticia is a descendant of the
Cabuesca people, she carries that blood and expresses it
at all times.
[Music] We
are navigating through the
indigenous territory of the Cahuáscar and
Yagan peoples, and for me it was inconceivable to do
this expedition without them.
[Music]  It
is divided into two
author margins, which are the interior channels,
and Malte, which are the exterior channels.
The important area for the Kabuascar goes
from the Gulf of Penas to the
Breg Peninsula, which borders
the territory
on this map. Could you tell us
where?  your ancestors used to fish, do
you have some notion of where they
were? Yes, but the territorial vision
is not through a nautical chart No,
mine is only of one sector. The one we
work on
is incredible. My dad's map is a
navigation chart that we  we still use
today It is very old and in it we
have been representing all the
spaces traveled what exists in
each one of the beaches, coves,
rocks, fishing corrals And that has
brought together the memories of my father
deep within that map
of these  These places are pristine, there
are also people who huescarillan who are
buried here. They are important places
for part of the territory, but the
government regulation indicates that within the
reserves there may be salmon farming.
Someone asked you if you
wanted the salmon farm to be installed
in your territory.
No  not even
the authorities now what we want is to
effectively demonstrate that yes in the
places that we say there are
natural banks so in this expedition what
we can do is contribute with
our studies to prove that those
places where they want to install the
salmon farms there is wealth and  there are
natural banks of marine species of
course
these native peoples who have been
here for more than six thousand years today are
completely threatened
salmon farming arrived in Chile some 30 years ago
it is having severe impacts on the
ecosystem and is also invading
territories that have  historically been
of native peoples
and that is why National Geographic can
provide scientific studies that serve
as a tool for these peoples so that they
can defend themselves against these threats. I
am a little nervous I navigated Yautock a lot
but I have never reached
Mars so far and that excites me a lot  The
truth is that
the Macro zone of fjords and channels of
Chilean Patagonia covers an
immense extension. We are talking about around
thousand kilometers of coastline and here
we are in this Kahuasca National Reserve,
which corresponds to the Marine part.
They are already operating in the
Cahuasca National Reserve.  this salmon industry
[Music]
to make the park and Eagle
[Music] we
are on desolation island
this Island is located in the westernmost point
of the expedition a few
kilometers from the open Pacific ocean
the temperature is around 11
degrees
thanks to
the  The visibility of the water is amazing,
we are talking about 20 meters of
visibility.
And that, floating inside that
forest with the rays of the sun, is an
unforgettable experience
[Music]
It's like the closest thing to being in a
giant architectural construction like a cathedral
[Music  ]
[Music]
this site has healthy gel forests they
are dense forests and
logically they must be protected
against potential threats that may
be associated with these places
[Music]
the sea the bottom of the ocean
the coastline the mountains the mountains
everything is very special
and everything is part of our ancestral territory
I found hummingbirds And that is very important to me it is
said that
they bring spirits of the ancients
of the ancestors
the birds
each bird and each animal has a story
in the world cabuesca
[Music] I
had never set foot near the  Tuesday
and for me it was super exciting because
the connection with the ancients is felt there the
deceased kabuascar travel to a
place called joyquialoué which is
beyond the horizon and there they stay
continuing with this navigation as forever
we are all descendants of
groups  skulls
we look for the ancients because
here everything we have done I have not
done by myself
no The kabuscar could have lived without
the oceans their main food is
there
the construction of canoes the
construction of the ads
of the sea itself takes off the coat that
The sea lions were for many
thousands of years,
so they could not have existed if
nature did not exist.
The area of ​​the Tierra del
Fuego archipelago where the
Kabuascan were, and here where we find the
Yagans, of course there are differences, but they are
very  similar And in this long
period of more than six thousand years in the
archaeological remains they realize
that the way of life of the knot centered on
the sea
[Music]
a place that is very cold, very
humid and a very important diet was needed,
very  strong in calories, a
management of fire in a very adequate way
to survive the humid environment
and I think that is what keeps it
strong today because they are the
people of the place of the territory
[Music]
in the history of  los kawakes What
significance does
Magellan's voyage through this area have?
[Music]
The truth is that it has no
meaning
here it was sailed a long, long time before,
so
Magellan's coming to us
means nothing, nothing special, it doesn't have
any relevance,
but it does mean  that Magellan
has given or has opened the door for
other Navigators to come here and
make the history of the indigenous people
of these territories change forever
and not in a good way
[Music]
we have the obligation to preserve
what exists
perhaps we  we are going to recover what
was there before but our obligation
is to maintain what exists and what
exists today is the territory and it is there
and there are the memories
[Music]
wins that huescar
yagan is left barefoot
as we  We entered the network of
fjords and channels in the eastern zone, we
began to find different
environments,
these islands are located in this
transition zone between the water with the least
salinity and the zone with the highest salinity
[Music]
one of the things that most amazed me about
the expedition consisted of the dives
we made in the kelp forests of the
Arriagada Islands
[Music] [
Music] [
Music]
my dad still uses
ancestral knowledge to navigate
fishing techniques have changed for
evolutionary reasons but we use
the  The same fishing spots that were
used perhaps thousands of years ago
in the same place are the
fishing beaches in the same place are the
natural banks of mussels and mussels
the extraction is always based on
what one is going to consume if we see the
territory we can say that it is
a large pantry
a caged salmon
And if I take everything out of the pantry then I
will have nothing left it is
the sea that makes us
navigation the most important thing for
us both materially and
spiritually
my Chilean name  It's Eric but my
real name and kahuasca are
my mother and Reinaldo is my grandfather.
My dad had a space where he stopped
identifying himself as indigenous.
discriminated against and that was a great burden
for him
so we started
working on it so that he would forget the resentment
he had against that contempt of
society until we recovered it and
now he is very proud
[Music]
fishing with my grandfather and touring the
territory sporadically all  life
[Music]
on this trip, well, very few
sea bass and one salmon came out and nothing else because the
fishing is exhausted due to the
pollution of the sea, it
turns out that the salmon farmers
believe they are Owners of the territory of the waters
[Music]
Six years ago you  I could catch up to 600
kilos of fish in the place,
however today we are
normally fishing between
60 to 90 kilos of fish.
Bass is super important to
us Because it constitutes a
fundamental part of the Food,
that is why it is super important for
us to protect it.  of the predation
that it is suffering nowadays by
the salmon that escape from the
salmon cages in large numbers
This is leading to the disappearance of the
sea bass Therefore it would also
mean the succession of a profound
ethnocide that is being experienced in this
place  of the territory
approximately 500 years ago
the writers and historians say that
there was a meeting here but there was no
meeting here there was an assault an
assault on the indigenous territories
[Music]
this place in a place to have
natural resources and generate business
to get rich mainly  in
relation to the territory
[Music]
the sea lion hunters spent
two three months hunting intensively
[Music]
also later that extends towards the
industry let's say the house of whales
on which they preyed and hunted
to the point of many cases almost taking it
to extinction
[Music]
[Music] [
Music]
there were kidnappings they
were taken to human zoos
unfortunately not my mom was like
when she was about six years old and
the fishermen took them to Punta
Arena their situation was more of a slave
than any other  person and her life is very sad
because after they took her
from her father's habitat she lost
contact with the whole family and he
really is a little sad because
every time she cut him her
eyes filled with tears
there was a massive extermination of
indigenous peoples that began in the Pampas with
the Tehuelches, the Houses were
displaced,
and the white man settled in the
archipelago and there began the
transmission of diseases, the
direct murder of the indigenous people, and
slowly the appropriation of the territory
and the archipelago by the first
The Europeans and later the
installation of the states of Chile and
Argentina
was, let's say, actually a genocide
[Music] they
are important places not only
here everything is clear everything everything
that has to do with the sites of
influence are important so that
Wesker Y yaganes in this case
and
we must try for them to
take care of them and continue the interaction
so that they do not lose their memory because
that is sometimes lost when it is no longer
said So we must not stop saying
clearly, we
must not stop saying it, I
was talking from  the ancient times and
I paid a lot of attention because they
are important stories
it was very significant for me to be there
with him who is the representative who went
with us on the expedition I
feel that emotion of gratitude
towards him because he, being from another
generation,
has wanted to go down  with me and for me that
is an honor
the connection is ancient between
cahuáscarillaganes they are groups that
have interacted since time immemorial
what unites us let's say is that the
groups that are not Eros Fishermen hunters
and gatherers
There they interacted in one way or another
always collecting or searching and
Looking for fire, that's why it's
called Tierra del Fuego, that's how
the Navigators called it Tierra del Fuego,
because it's
super important to keep it,
all the indigenous people gathered around
the fire,
it's necessary to return to that interaction and
to be United and allies for the
protection of the territories
[  Music]
[Music]
salinity
5.79 temperature 1.8
moving
s
[Music] [
Music]
one feels tiny I am
looking at an
ancient landscape but what causes me is that
there and there too  It was a
glacier and there was much more ice and there was
much more of everything so it also causes me
a kind of
sadness of
restlessness
[Music] [
Music] [
Music]
[Music]
I'm looking at this cage that doesn't have
bird mesh
and  there is another one over there that does have
aviary mesh so I think they are
small salmon
so that conception over there is
active
Yes there are many here
these were this was a fishing channel that
we used before
and now we can no longer use it makes
me very angry  It doesn't make me sad, it makes me
angry. It
was an investment. The investment. To
us, who had always
worked freely and calmly. We
are in a really clean area of
Patagonia, between Estero Poca
Esperanza and Estero Valdés. The beauty
is impressive. And unfortunately,
we found a huge salmon farm.
I imagine the impacts that a structure
and an operation of this type can have
in an ecosystem as fragile as this
[Music] that
's why little Esperanza doesn't leave anymore,
it spoils the bar, leaves it without oxygen
Therefore, the native species die
these  In turn, these species are useful for
us to live on. There are many families
that still subsist on fishing.
Harvesting is almost
completely incompatible with the
preservation of Patagonia and also
with sustainable economic activities
such as tourism and artisanal fishing.
It is a very remote area and therefore  Therefore, the
invasion that was in the industry
means that in an area like this it
really leaves us very, very surprised,
it is very painful. The truth is that
we do not have any need to
imagine the impacts that
harmonica can have in Patagonia, we
know it because we have more than 30 years
of experience.  of this activity in this
part of Chile
[Music]
My name is Mario Eloy Ángel Uribe I'm
from
the Liceo I studied as I said an aquaculture technician
now I'm not going to austral a car ago
I fired on September 22
most of the jobs I
did are  Inside the Agostini National Park,
which is located south of
Punta Arenas
[Music]
the natural environment of the Agustín Park I
think it is one of the most
beautiful places I have seen after the place
where I originally live,
so a beautiful beautiful place Always very
beautiful
I was an opponent it has been all kinds
of work but there were always
illegal practices in this case
[Music]
The Sea Lions stay very close to
the coasts where the centers are because of
the amount of fish there and the
food The Sea Wolves suck
the fish from  the same tights or they
also go inside the cages to
eat
company they did nothing but in
practice they literally killed them they
killed them with a spear sometimes with a
shotgun also
sunk they caught them in tights later
they appeared there they drowned
[Music]
yes I saw massacres of  lobo Yes, all of this
within a national park clearly
the modification of funds that they made
in cupboard 14 in the agostini park
was on purpose that was planned
the law was executed It says that for the concessions
to continue operating there must
be aerobic situations where there is
life  if not, they cannot continue operating That
was what they wanted to hide the
anaerobic situation in this case that there
was no life
all this happened inside the
Agustín National Park let's
not normalize it that we don't do it
something normal to destroy our
territory for
external lucrative economic purposes  outside that
the community does not benefit either and
move it to a sanctuary or a park
where
the sacred places of
pre-existing communities will not be respected in this case
And I think that is a total lack of
respect towards the communities that
are from here  This area,
the Magallanes region, is still
little occupied by these salmon farms, but it
is being subjected to strong pressure from
the industry to be able to install much
more of these cages in the Magallanes fjords.
If the salmon industry continues to
expand, what we are going to lose are
the  The last kabuascars that are
sailing over this territory we are going to
lose many native species that
have lived with the kabuascars for
thousands of years
we cannot allow the
memory that exists in the territory to be
destroyed
Lenny
the difference in
salinity and temperature that we find is impressive
In this area we have a whole gradient
from this area
to the east as we move further west
I was surprised because the
scientific studies agreed a lot How
the territory is divided in an ancestral way
let's continue verifying that one side is
yautoc the other enamel and the one that always
We  we have said that enamel is also
[Music]
And if we combine the word of the indigenous people
with scientific knowledge and we can
verify that both have good
results, then we can make a
question that takes on such power that
no one will be able to knock it down
[Music  ]
In a certain amount of time, it is limited
by the group of species
found in those places, she
says because she knows and has shown me
many places where they worked from
there, she was also with her father,
I am going to take all of this.
Let's take it for me
to show it My community
is also charged with energy, having gotten to
know the native peoples much better
has really recharged us
with strength to continue supporting the
conservation of Patagonia,
always wonderful, of the
natural heritage that Chile has in these fjords
and channels  as well as other great
patrimonies when we talk about the Amazon
this is also like for Chile a
jungle these macroalgae forests full
of species
it is an area still swimming pool that is not
found in other places
This is a treasure And what will happen
when we lose it How much would we pay  to
rebuild this, however, it will be
impossible
we are trying to protect the last thing we
have left
we cannot lose more
and the government must understand that it is
imperative to protect it
[Music] [
Applause]
white
defend arm and also the forest
That means
we are on point  tree and in front of an
old cahuáscar camp that has
a lot of history the truth is that these
beaches were all traveled by
our ancients
and we got together to light
fires to protect the territory
the fire
has an uncontrollable spirit
so it should never be left alone it
should always  taking care of oneself
[Music]
the fire
is reborn as a symbolic thing
[Music]
but it has an ancestral history
when they set fire before it is a
way of bringing the children closer to the
little ones and ourselves to the
territory
today for us we revive it to  that
precisely the new generations
can connect with the old ones
to tell each one their experience and
we can nurture the little ones
with the ancient stories
this fire ceremony was born as a result of
the protection of the territory
the fire continues to have a story
and will continue to have  depending on
what we give him
[Music]